oh that's too hard I know it's too hard
but what's the one thing that you think
or maybe the most proud of and the most
fun
uh listen there's a lot of babies that
I've been part of and giving birth to
it's unfortunate so I'm not trying to
hurt anything but I would say Malibu's
I'm really proud of because that was an
idea that I had and to Shepherd it all
the way from my idea to concept to
script to sail to movie to successful
movie to now being this like cold hit
that made me feel good and it validated
me as a person to say oh okay my idea is
actually
or some yes I love her hey there folks
it's Michael Rosenbaum and boy have I
got a huge announcement for you this has
been a long time coming and it's finally
here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember and he's been on the podcast
he's a friend of the show the one the
only Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up
on life and mental health and we're
gonna have a really good time with all
of you I think you know that we're going
to make it a lot of fun we're planning a
q a maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there